president Trump not backing down in his
push to reopen the country this came
during an announcement about
fast-tracking a vaccine take a look it's
called Operation warp speed
that means big and it means fast its
objective is to finish developing and
then to manufacture and distribute a
proven coronavirus vaccine as fast as
possible vaccine or no vaccine we're
back and we're starting the process and
states are seeing a difference in
reactions to how they are reopening
political criticizing media coverage of
how red state governors like Florida's
Ron de santis handle the lockdowns
while New York's Governor Andrew Cuomo
is now facing more scrutiny for his
handling of the pandemic after
previously receiving high marks Dana as
we go into this reopening phase I have a
feeling like we're just in a grand
experiment lives are on the line what
are you thinking I think we're doing I
think it's more than just an experiment
oh of course you could look at as Greg
as mentioned 50 different experiments
and that's kind of a useful way to look
at it but I do feel like aside from the
extremes like in Los Angeles cutting off
water to businesses that's an extreme
and maybe revelers in Wisconsin that
could be an extreme but the extremes are
hijacking the debate what you actually
see is that governors are using data to
inform their decisions such as governor
De Santis and governor Kemp and they
have won they would be responsible for
the consequences of their decisions but
they're based it on data people have
been fairly responsible and they're
seeing their numbers continue to come
down and they're recognizing that
they're going to have to help their
businesses have to figure out a way to
reopen safely and responsibly the other
thing is you know the government cannot
be your parent the government can't do
everything for you we are responsible
citizens we are responsible adults we
are blessed to live in a free country
and the government has to trust us that
we will make the decision for ourselves
there might be extremes but that is
absolutely not the vast majority of
what's happening and I would also say
say a prayer for some of these local
officials that
to make some really tough decisions talk
to the mayor of Point Pleasant Beach
today Paul Quneitra he was on a daily
briefing talking about how they're going
to reopen beaches yeah it's not gonna be
easy to tell people if they're in a line
that they're gonna have to wear a mask
while they're at the beach they're gonna
have to have patrols etc they're trying
to do it with care and we should
understand and give them some room to
try to do what they need to do so that
we can all reopen and get this country
moving again yeah
so Greg coming to this idea you know
Jane is talking about beaches the
weather's getting better there's going
to be more people outside and I think
people if they are outside and keeping a
social distance I think there's a better
shot at avoiding trouble than when we're
indoors kind of huddled with the virus
around what do you think oh I've always
felt that way and I've said it many
times because the first I think the
first suggestion about this virus was
that it was spread via indoors it's an
indoor sickness so I think it's I think
it's a really really smart idea to get
people outside as the weather gets
warmer as for people who continue to
accuse others of murder when they want
to go outside and feed their families
flip the script when they accuse you of
wanting death say to them will you want
more spousal abuse because domestic
violence has been surging as these
restrictions linger right so if they say
you want people to die so well you want
spouses to get beaten up obviously
that's absurd
but it's analogous and that's what the
media right now is doing to people who
just want to get back to work
so you got to flip it on them piece of
advice from Gregg's all right candidate
we appreciate it thank you thank you
Kennedy I'm wondering what is practical
what can we really do until the summer
camps and the school's get reopened and
I know you have kids so I just wanted to
hear your thoughts on how extensive can
any reopening be if the kids are the
kids have nowhere to go no it's true
there's so much pressure on parents
right now not only are we
in charge of schooling and education and
curriculum and being taskmasters and
making sure that everything is turned in
on time and everyone is attending their
their zum meetings you also have to keep
your kids physically active and that's
that's a very big challenge the one nice
thing about it is it is bringing people
together and sort of reinventing what
physical fitness means and getting
outside and walking together properly
socially distance I think that's a great
thing and it also it leaves it up to
families what are we comfortable doing
and to Dana's point yes it's a it's a
laboratory of democracy and that every
state is going to open differently just
like every person is going to come back
from an injury differently but also
every business and every parent has to
think for themselves what is the best
way to keep my family safe while still
functioning and to Greg's point it is a
false dichotomy it's not open up the
states and people die or stay at home
and the economy craters long-term there
has to be something in the middle and we
have to be trusted as individuals to
thread that needle I think that's a good
point so Jessie let's come to the media
angle on this story you saw that
political critical of the American media
for having previously been so critical
of Florida's Ron de santis the governor
when he was leaving the beaches open the
like and the reality is now we don't see
any large-scale outbreaks in Florida on
the other hand very high praise for lots
of Republican governors I'm thinking of
the wine of Ohio Hogan and Marilyn Baker
in Massachusetts so is it fair to say
the media has been unfair to Republican
governors yeah like what does the
santa´s need to do put some Infected
people in nursing homes to get a puff
piece written about them
I mean Cuomo's God and this guy botched
it and people are dead in nursing homes
and it's getting worse they did this all
over the Northeast like Pennsylvania did
the same thing and now there's a huge
scandal because the Pennsylvania Health
Director withdrew her own mother from a
nursing home while she forced other sick
people to go into the nursing homes and
now thousands of people have been killed
and if the media had reported these
things early on every other governor in
the country could have looked at that
and said you know what maybe we
shouldn't be doing that